see we give that a shot easier said than
done he's asking if he should do it wild
one motorcycle one foot
like it's the detail on the character
model with each individual weapon see
exactly what is caring all right here we
go here we go you know what to do its
target one its target one get a little
distance there we go let's go dad there
we go back up there we go target too
little for me missed that one is so it's
wow don't bucket we're gonna book it see
if we can get another barrel see if we
found another one
there's one on the Left lives where they
originated that we got to be strategic
bear wow this is really appreciate
anything
what's the game plan MJ what we're doing
couple we're like one or two more on us
all right ain't giving up like that
all right here we go this is the run I
believe here this is the run this is it
got some molotov action nice let's go
Wow alright that's the key one right
there that's the key one nice
Oh truck Wow
looking in scrambling oh he's scrambling
now I'm assuming that burn damage to the
zombies that again that's damage over
time Dave they will eventually
okay there it is there it is
I'm richer bro I'm Richie I like to
build what we doing
I like the vision let's go guys still
still so many even after all that this
is intense nice or is the boss is
working that now he's doing
Oh get him MJ go boy are you so close
you so close he was so close and we got
some live footage we got some love
we got some freaker's they're here days
go on stable get them under control one
last shot for the road this is it this
be the last one this last but whatever
this is a do or die
we're going down with going down with a
ship on this one last attempt y'all days
gone and savor stuff riggers your post
added that last week read you got a big
chunk out I like the I try that Molitor
fantasy yeah now about the freakish
themself they react on site obviously or
do they react on sound also oh nice so
you have to be quiet you have to do
stealth mechanics to get around nice
all right got some loose ones in the
field nice look at a weave good speaking
of which have anybody beat this section
yet I know it's early in packs but don't
give up it's going down good as hell it
was a good attempt Dave's gone again
April release April 26 one of the most
highly anticipated PlayStation 4
releases and we're excited man an
absolute pleasure to have you in the
realm game looks fantastic man thank you
so much for your time